tim the tool man taylor first burst onto
our tv screens back in 1991 and no
matter how big tim allen's star got he
always came back to his home improvement
rooms my wife says when i put this bad
boy on i turn into wild hairy disgusting
ape huh
this show's gonna be everything we're
gonna show people how to be real we're
gonna beam life will zoom from your eye
just say shut up when you want me to
shut up
for eight seasons et was right there
alongside tim and nearly 30 years after
the first episode came this full circle
moment tim the tool man taylor came face
to face with last man standings mike
baxter tim taylor mike baxter you know
this is just like the parent trap only
gets the grandparent trap
how does it feel to be playing him and
playing yourself is that weird for you
not what i expected it was very
difficult and then having people direct
me and the character i developed 20
years ago i was pretty famous myself i
had this tv show for eight years called
tool time and yet here you are
and while we're hoping for a future home
improvement reunion we kind of had a
mini one when we brought tim and richard
carne back together both of us are still
close i mean i still see richard way too
much boy wait it just doesn't feel like
30 years no it doesn't i never told you
this tim but you're like a brother to me
look out oh all right
i think it resonates with the with the
parents that grew up with it are now
being able to show their kids something
that they can sit all together and watch
y'all know fans of the nanny have been
waiting for a reboot ever since the show
ended over two decades ago right so
could it happen i got the answers and
one really fun flashback with the one
and only charles shaughnessy that's how
she became the nanny
what's the secret sauce for you in in
france i think we just knew how to play
off each other we trusted each other and
it took off like a rocket i wonder like
behind the scenes or even a favorite
memory or a favorite yeah
i have to say the guest stars elizabeth
i'm so sorry i didn't know you had
already arrived oh didn't you hear the
buzzer elizabeth taylor elton john right
up to coolio who at the time and and and
uh billy ray
i mean just everyone you could imagine
came through what do you remember most
about the wedding episode um not a lot
like it was like a real wedding you know
it was just a blur
well e.t was behind the scenes for that
1998 episode
[Music]
it's not like there's a real wedding
going on i mean i've lost weight charles
says he knew back then once their
on-screen relationship turned romantic
that would be the kiss of death for the
show's longevity it was canceled the
following year this is the worst
nightmare probably just beginning with
them getting married now she's mrs
jeffrey she has to introduce her to all
his uh relations and she talks like this
what's the matter with the way i talk
nothing donnie we knew that that was
kind of a death now yeah when you've got
a relationship built on this sort of
sexual tension um getting married is
like the last thing you want to do we
did it but we were like
oh well
so you know that fran is working on a
musical version yeah of the series what
do you think about an updated reboot of
the tv
i i you know we've talked about it and
um she actually had a really genius idea
did you tell her i'm in if this goes
okay yeah yeah i was very hesitant about
anything and then i heard that and it
went oh that'll work fran and charles
will forever remain tv royalty and he's
also kind of royalty in real life years
ago he inherited the title lord charles
shaughnessy now what are the perks of
being a lord a kind of slightly mouldy
row
and that's it i was hoping for i was
hoping for like a family fortune a
castle somewhere we get commanded to um
to
attend the next coronation whether it's
charles or william you're going to be
we'll be there putting on our little
crowns in the background
well if you need a plus one charles just
saying
now from a cbs sitcom classic to one of
the most iconic dramas of all time
dallas and mr bobby ewing himself
patrick duffy so to say that he was
excited to be part of this exclusive tv
tribe well
that would be an understatement
we are doing this this franchise the
iconic
men of the 90s you know we promised to
give it a shot right when you hear that
and that's attached to patrick duffy
what do you think about that word iconic
it's better than being arp's sexiest man
still alive
you know so i'll take anything i can get
at this stage there's no other word but
icon to describe patrick's 90s
domination
oh my god
in 1991 he ended a 13-year reign playing
bobby ewing in the legendary primetime
drama dallas tell me about bobby ewing
how would you describe him god you look
like you just saw a ghost
listen there was a lot of us who
worshipped at the church
okay well then there you go
i don't know what kind of kicks you get
out of hurting people but it's time you
started paying for it
duffy told me off-screen he had a
real-life brotherhood with co-star larry
hagman larry was from the moment we met
we became best friends to literally i
was with him maybe an hour and a half
before he died and linda gray we were
the three musketeers it was the best job
i've ever had i got to play with my two
best friends for 16 years when the show
was finally canceled i had two weeks off
and signed my step-by-step contract
were you ready to do a comedy well i was
ready uh i'm not sure the world was
patrick's on-screen wife suzanne summers
even had her doubts when we visited the
set of the tgif family sitcom in 1991.
my first when they said patrick duffy i
said
yeah but
is he funny you know i mean i've only
seen him on dallas you've got you've
come a long way since bobby ewing yeah
yeah he'd be lost without me
[Laughter]
suzanne became my larry best friend's
first day well we're in the land of
reboots would you ever think about
revisiting that with her the
step-by-step reboot has been discussed
we were one of the first sitcoms where
the two adults had a real sexual
relationship for each other's best
presence
yeah that's right can i unwrap my nose
okay and we cut
come on i think that audiences need to
see that okay honey
we got a show patrick's honey is former
happy days actress linda pearl you
really are a great looking couple
thank you thank you thank you their
quarantine love story is one for the
ages they began a long long-distance
zooming relationship for months before
patrick got in his car and drove a day
straight and arrived on her doorstep i
was standing out in the driveway jumping
up and down i've made a total fool of
myself it's remarkable that you didn't
turn around no well and the other side
of it is that i drove all those hours
and i was five minutes from her house
and i pulled over because i was in my 23
hour driving clothes and in the middle
of a colorado springs street i'm
dropping trowel outside my outside my
car
i'm putting on a good pair of slacks
i gargled smelled my breath
got back in the car and drove up like
this is how i look
[Music]
you